what's up everyone this is GQ recommends
today we're going to be talking about
vintage cheese and we're going to show
you how we wear them to the office
so vintage tees as the category is
really broad but there are subcategories
within that like vintage music tees
vintage novelty t-shirts also vintage
sportswear like old ring or teas or old
football t-shirts and then they're just
vintage blanks plain no Graphics they
want something that has some character
and some fading distressing to it I
think the benefit of vintage tees
generally is that there's a story behind
it and whether that's one you make with
it or that already came along with it
when you bought it there's going to be a
narrative there honestly it's a really
good conversation starter it's something
that someone can come up to you and have
something to say about you know it's a
bumper sticker that you can wear
[Music]
this is a vintage Pat Sajak t-shirt he
had his own talk show in the late 80s I
found it at this vintage store and I saw
the back of it which is sort of you know
the hidden secret and best part of it
that sort of completes the joke it's got
one of those old school sort of 80s
ringer tea fits right where it's not
like too billowy and big like a 90s T
and not too like skin tight like a t
from like the 60s and it's really funny
this is just an outfit full of fun
things that I love to wear all the time
these white pants are from jound got my
cowboy boots on this striped Blazer
that's kind of preppy and kind of old
school and kind of fun from a brand
called Onslow you know the T-shirt sort
of just ties it all together there's a
world in which wearing slacks and a
blazer could come off really formal or
dressy or Stuffy the T-shirt kind of
helps to break things up and keep things
fresh and fun
[Music]
I got this shirt in 2015 at Search and
Destroy on St Marks I was having a
really deep fascination with the Insane
Clown Posse and it's really nice because
whenever I wear it now I'll kind of get
a stranger giving me a gentle whoop
whoop um when I walked on the sidewalk
if I ever had the chance to go to a
gathering I would love to go
wait it's become kind of one of my
favorite shirts it's printed on a XL
stadman by Haynes shirt really
comfortable like I'm convinced that
vintage stores must wash all their
shirts with like rocks and fabric
softener and that's why it's so perfect
and slouchy
I think in order to make an Insane Clown
Posse shirt appropriate for an office
um I tried to dress it up a little bit I
put on just a white button down
underneath these Sherman Williams
branded Dickies just recently found them
at a vintage store in Rockaway Beach and
a little Rachel Comey flat to make it
business casual
as far as it can be
oh
this is a vintage Guy Harvey shirt that
I bought on eBay Guy Harvey is a fishing
brand that I associate with like
Southern Frack guys I just found myself
wanting one for myself it's fun to take
it out of context when you think about
vintage shorts or even just like tees I
would say start with like what you're
into I don't skate so I don't really
want you know supreme or Palace or
whatever I don't like the Grateful Dead
really so like the whole tie-dye thing
is sort of off limits but I do fix and
it's like okay I'm gonna get some
fishing gear the association with these
sorts of shorts is usually it's like
fish that you're gonna go out and kill
you know it's like Marlins or something
and I like that it was turtles because
it's not that it's just like
appreciating like a nice looking animal
my office style is pretty low-key these
days after the pandemic I used to get
dressed up for the office but uh not so
much anymore I'm wearing vintage Levi
501s and Birkenstocks these are a jewel
sander collaboration with Birkenstocks
like I said this is sort of like a frat
guy brand so it's probably more natural
with like some pleated khaki shorts and
like top ciders so like some beat up old
jeans and Birkenstocks it's like a way
to take it out of its you know context
and freak it a little bit
so this is my vintage t-shirt it says
Merv is the word it's from a department
store based on the west coast that
went bankrupt it's like 1990s I actually
got this from my mom whenever I visit
them at home I'll just like go through
their closet my mom and my dad they're
both immigrated to California so they
don't really get rid of stuff so there's
just cool things lying around and it's
pretty cool because I feel like I'm like
carrying my mom with me around in the
city
so I'm wearing this shirt with a pair of
sweaty pants that I got at a vintage
store in La jean jackets always solid
go-to for the office because it's so
chilly pairing with some dunks
the reason why I love wearing t-shirts a
lot is because I feel like the most
confident and I think that's the best
thing about finding your personal style
I play sports too so with Nike shoes
vintage track pants
it's me
I don't like to buy a lot of things
unless I feel really good that I'm gonna
wear it a lot of times I know Big Sean
has like a really big vintage tea
collection I like his collection because
he also looks for shirts that speak to
his history or interests and I think
that's what makes a good vintage tea I
recommend people look for vintage
t-shirts in their parents closets
honestly where I got mine there's so
much gold to be found just like inside
your own home and there's like cool
story that you could tell parents
closets the best vintage stores
this is my favorite vintage tea I bought
it about a year ago and I wear it
probably once a week it's from early 90s
late 80s it's kind of got this ironic
Motif going on here where it lists all
the popular ad campaigns from that era
and then says God is like the product
that's ostensibly being advertised on
the back it says God is great it's made
out of cotton fits super well which I'm
really picky about so like the collar
comes up pretty high and it won't Wilt
on you halfway through the day it's
pretty long and boxy too which is
typical of how teas would fit during
that time
I think I've worn this t-shirt with like
everything that I have in my closet I've
worn it with striped long shorts flared
dress pants high-waisted trousers I
probably wear like some variation on
this outfit once or twice a week this is
just Adidas sneakers vintage Levi's 505s
and tuxedo jacket because I have to do
something later tonight and I want it to
look somewhat put together my ad is also
vintage
I've never been to Santa Fe have no
plans of going
I would recommend looking at a store
called chickies vintage in Williamsburg
that's where I bought this tea they
specialize in like Art House slightly
off Kilt their t-shirts if that's your
Vibe it's a good place to start
[Music]
blue t-shirt I'm wearing today is just a
plain white t-shirt which maybe isn't so
exciting but I've had it for jeez I want
to say since middle school this brand is
still around and it's not one we often
talk about just a brand that you find at
Kmart or something R.I.P it's called
Alan Sally but I think this tea is maybe
from like
maybe 2000 2001. this is definitely
something I wear you know pretty often
for me it's all about the silhouette
really I just have vintage Brooks
Brothers pants I just like how they
drape a lot and then mules from our
Legacy
these trousers are pressed and they have
pleats and a crease they're properly
tailored and this is just like
[ __ ] up I guess
I mean I wouldn't necessarily say like a
moth pole written shirt is appropriate
for the office unless you work at GQ or
something but maybe your boss is cool
like that I don't know
there are plenty of shops that I go to
online or in person pretty regularly
Waco vintage they have so many vintage
t-shirts and they break it down by like
era by musician intramural is a really
great shop the teas that he carries
aren't going to be like oh an old AC DC
shirt it's going to be like a t-shirt
from an old like Furniture designer or I
think he recently had like a vintage
Philip Glass t-shirt so that's a really
good one too
[Music]
I'm wearing a 1994 Benetton Formula One
tee I got it because I have gone to F1
and got into Michael Schumacher and
found out that he used to race for
benaton and then found out that they
made really awesome shirts post you know
scouring eBay and Etsy for any sort of
like old Benetton shirt I found out that
it was from the year that Schumacher won
his first drivers championship and I was
like I grab it
it's nice I like the theme too I like
that like it's a Racing shirt and I pair
it with vintage German Army trainers
that kind of look like driving shoes so
it kind of all fits together it's a
little small but I pair with big pants I
do the big pants tiny shirt luck meme
because you can't always choose your
size with a vintage tape SGA he's got a
crazy collection he goes more with like
the old raptis than I do some people
look really good in an old 90s beefy tea
or like a boxy cut I think it looks
weird for my body but what makes a good
vintage tea is that you like it
this is a shirt that was my mom's when
she was in college like late 80s early
90s I love it because it's one of those
huge easy shirts that just get softer
and softer every time you wear it it's
even like getting like really stretched
out in the neck little holes in the
shoulder it's super worn in super comfy
this is a Varney shirt Barney France I
hope I'm saying that right it's one of
those brands that you don't really hear
of anymore I feel but it was kind of
like the brand to have in the late 90s
and I was like doing a Google and you
can find really cool ones on grilled and
stuff now
I'm wearing it with a rowing Blazers
tennis skirt and then I just wore my new
balance because comfort and I love the
way it looks with a little American
trench sock sometimes I might even like
throw over a sweater over my shoulders
do a preppy look or even a Blazer and
make it a little bit more dressy
I would say that I'm still growing my
vintage tea collection in vintage
collection overall in New York I love
stock vintage and Raggedy threads Front
Street General in Brooklyn is really
good but I have a lot of great pieces
that I tend to steal from my parents
closet because they don't care about
their old stuff from the 90s and 80s but
I think it's so cool I'm like where's
this been hiding bring it back out like
let me wear it
foreign